charli's is bombshell co-star Nicole
Kidman joining TV's million-dollar Club
yeah you let it
variety reports Hulu will give Nicole a
militant 2020 to bring this book to TV
recent Morning Show co-star Jen already
make double that but Steve Carell
750,000 next year Netflix could make him
a Million Dollar Man with upcoming
comedy series space force we all have
hearts that scare us
Kerry Washington may max soon-to-be
co-star reese's million on Hulu's
upcoming show little fires everywhere on
broadcast salaries are smaller variety
reports the pearsons all pull in 250k an
episode on this is us while this modern
family gets 500 cardi B reportedly got
that for rhythm and flow on Netflix yeah
stranger things happen on streaming
Winona Ryder
David Harbour and Millie Bobby Brown
reportedly pullin three hundred and
fifty grand
the other kids most get 250 by
comparison Rob Lowe is said to be making
fifty thousand less for Fox's upcoming
nine-one-one spin-off I don't know how
this has happened to me doing TV used to
be taboo for movie stars put variety
hints Leo Brad or Tom could fetch two
million in episode heads bellroy chris
pratt is already reportedly eyeing a
small screen role with a per episode
paycheck of 1.4 million oh come on don't
be so amazing
[Music]